[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson's design happy tuesday we'll
admit it up front we can't get off this
martha's vineyard store because there's
just so much there
so last week you'll recall
our venezuelan visitors to this country
our brothers and sisters as they're now
known on cnn took what amounted to the
shortest vacation ever recorded to
martha's vineyard they were on that
island for just hours less than two full
days it was hardly enough time to pick
up a fair trade coffee at mocha motts in
vineyard haven or go kite boarding on
south beach
in fact we have literally been talking
about their trip longer than it lasted
it was that brief
on the other hand so was the moon
landing so as the wright brothers first
flight at kitty hawk duration is no
measure of a fact
those brief hours our venezuelan
brothers and sisters spent on martha's
vineyard changed history and left what
they're calling an indelible mark on the
people who lived there they enriched us
said one resident we were happy to help
them on their journey
unfortunately as it turned out that
journey ended abruptly at a military
base on cape cod where our venezuelan
brothers and sisters are now being held
against their will
prisoners in a country they thought was
their own
they're no mokamats where they are now
kiteboarding is completely out of the
question it's just a bitter dream at
this point
now the people of martha's vineyard knew
this was going to happen and yet
none of them thought to tell their
venezuelan brothers and sisters before
it happened quote i kept telling them it
was like a dormitory said jackie
stallings who lives on the island as
soldiers arrived to deport her
venezuelan siblings i didn't want to say
you're going to a military base well of
course not it's a dormitory just like
your dad sent your elderly dog to a farm
because he'll be happier there
but the venezuelans are not happier in
military lock-up they loved martha's
vineyard
as they told msnbc they considered it a
paradise
they left here a few minutes ago their
move to cape cod to the joint basin cape
cod with new clothes new cell phones
haven't talked to lawyers for the first
time and saying that they were actually
brought to paradise they don't resent it
for now
and they know they're the lucky ones
so finally one reporter over at nbc news
tells the truth about what is actually a
pretty sad story our venezuelan brothers
and sisters came to this country for a
better life and unlike so many they
actually found it they arrived in one of
the prettiest and most affluent
destinations on the planet an idyllic
island with unlimited resources and many
thousands of empty beds and best of all
a population that claimed to love them
no person is illegal read the lawn signs
but it was all a lie
50 brown people was too many for the
people of martha's vineyard they called
in the army to have them removed like
trash as one island resident said
so actually judging by the behavior and
not simply by their lawn signs which is
the best way to judge people the people
of martha's vineyard are not especially
compassionate in fact they're
small-minded and cheap and pretty nasty
as any waiter or babysitter who works on
the island can tell you
so once again the ones who claim to be
the best people are actually the worst
people
remember when jimmy swagger got busted
with hookers and porn it's very much
like that
the truth turns out to be the opposite
of what they told you it was it's highly
embarrassing
but here's the weird thing on martha's
video they're not embarrassed at all
jimmy schwagert famously apologized for
his sins because he had shame
but the people of martha's vineyard have
no shame and so they're not apologizing
in fact against all evidence they're now
bragging about how wonderful they are
yesterday kerry picket of the washington
times caught up with martha's vineyard's
senior senator that'd be ms elizabeth
warren of massachusetts listen to
elizabeth warren's version of the
martha's vineyard story
is it getting a bad rap right now
martha's vineyard
yeah no oh i think they did
the people of martha's vineyard opened
their hearts
and were helpful
to
the migrants
who were deceived
and
dropped there in a
privately chartered jet
and treated like a prop
for
a governor
who's just trying to make news
well if nothing else it's interesting to
see history
history that we've watched unfold
a story in which the facts are not at
all in dispute
get rewritten in real time and you
wonder how many other stories have been
rewritten but we can see this one being
rewritten
in elizabeth warren's telling actually
the people of martha's vineyard are the
heroes
and ron desantis is the villain
because he deceived them
now we just heard and it's again
factually not in dispute that island
residents deceived their venezuelan
siblings by telling them they were just
going to a dorm they're not being locked
up on a military base like
so actually the people of martha's
vineyard
the residents there are the ones who did
the tricking they tricked the
venezuelans into going to a military
base but that wasn't deception now
according to elizabeth warren it was an
act of love but at some point whatever
the people of martha's vineyard got what
they wanted everything is back to normal
there the people who live there are
relieved they're not going to be 50
needing minorities in their midst to
spoil of usual festivities and that
would include the
food and wine festival
[Music]
each year for the past decade more than
2500 food and wine enthusiasts converge
on the island of martha's vineyard for a
culinary and wine extravaganza so have
an oyster then taste the wine then have
your other oyster and taste the wine
again that's the routine for each one so
two oysters per wine see how the oyster
tastes on its own see how you like the
flavors of the wine with the oyster the
martha's vineyard food and wine festival
four days and three nights of
celebration
so just so you know
you taste the wine and then you eat the
oyster then you taste the wine again
okay and the way they mesh in your mouth
those
flavors the complexity of them
it's like an explosion on your palate
and that's why thousands of people come
to martha's vineyard every year for that
festival but guess who doesn't come
venezuelans
unless they're serving the oysters and
pouring the wine
so really we could go on at great length
about this because it's just such a
great story and reveals so much but it's
much bigger than the now established
fact that martha's vineyard is populated
by nasty liberals who don't tip and
don't actually want colored people in
their midst that's true we know that now
but the bigger story and the one that
affects the rest of us the other 340
million people who live here is that
what we saw in martha's vineyard is in
fact just a taste of what is absolutely
the official policy of the democratic
party and it is this
if your town votes the right way then
you get military protection the military
shows up immediately 50 people not
hurting anybody and the army comes to
remove them can you imagine
talk about a 9-1-1 call that's pretty
great all you need to do is vote 80 for
joe biden and you can do that
and throw some donations this way too
but what about everybody else
well everyone else is sol and that would
include all of us
over the past 11 months american
authorities have encountered more than 2
million illegals along the southern
border that's the highest number ever
recorded by the us government
at least another 1 million were allowed
into this country as so-called economic
migrants meaning they want better jobs
because who doesn't want a better job
hundreds thousands more we don't know
the number but clearly hundreds of
thousands just sneaked in that's
according to the official data now how
many of those are headed to military
bases for deportation in how many cases
did the u.s military arrive
to solve what is so clearly a disaster
zero
because it wasn't martha's vineyard now
we've been making a documentary on this
a documentary on the board it's called
battle for the borders coming out later
this year and in the course of reporting
that out we obtained this footage
showing how some of these illegal aliens
enter this country these pictures were
shot on july 23rd this year
how you doing everyone
state police
where you from
huh
pakistan
what y'all doing here
keep your hands out of your pocket
you got any weapons on you
you got an id
no ideas
so when people on martha's vineyard
think of
illegal immigration they really think
grounds keepers and waiters and people
who work at the back end of the kitchen
people who clean up or
prepare the food
that's what illegal immigration is to
them
they're not really thinking none of us
are really thinking that people might be
showing up from pakistan really pakistan
they didn't walk
by the way isn't pakistan the place
where isis has just called for jihadis
to enter the united states and kill
americans why these guys walking on a
road in texas
now during their interview with the
police both of the men you just saw
admitted they were here illegally they
said they each paid thousands of dollars
to be smuggled into the united states
this is very common now it's not the
immigration you remember
who are these people do they mean us
harm it's not simply a matter of
competing for jobs with american
citizens
it's potentially a grave threat and a
lot of people like this are coming
across the border right now here's fox's
bill malugion
for the very first time a brand new fox
news drone equipped with thermal imaging
captures images of mass illegal
crossings in the middle of the night in
eagle pass texas this morning migrants
could be seen crossing the river and
walking onto private property where over
100 gathered and waited for border
patrol processing sometimes the del rio
sector here gets upwards of 2 000
illegal crossings in a single day and
this was only one of three huge groups
we have already seen so far this morning
and it's not even noon yet out here take
a look at this second group we saw this
was another group of about 200 who
crossed illegally and started walking
along a local highway out here this is
how it is in eagle pass you can just be
driving down the road and you'll see
large groups of several hundred migrants
just walking down the highway waiting to
be picked up and apprehended by border
patrol
so we're just getting word right now
that the white house many white house
officials are telling quote journalists
that they are very annoyed by bill
malugen's reporting it's quote alarmist
in other words unlike reporters the
washington post and the new york times
bill millucian doesn't think that he
works for joe biden
he's taking pictures of what's actually
happening and that's wrong
what's interesting given what is
happening which is that we are being
invaded by people with no right to be
here for reasons that we don't really
understand
is that none of the people who are
complaining about ron desantis sending
50 venezuelans to martha's vineyard have
said a word about what else is happening
on the border and a lot is happening
it's an ongoing humanitarian disaster a
tragedy for the people being trafficked
and they are being trafficked
but it's also an ongoing disaster for us
who live here it's our country
as militant reported human traffickers
are loading more than a dozen people
into the backs of cars right now which
is a disaster watch this
fox news was with texas dps troopers as
they pulled over a human smuggler from
michigan
hidden inside his trunk two illegal
immigrants from honduras all of them
arrested and in kinney county texas dps
troopers pulled over this van and were
shocked when they found 16 illegal
immigrants being smuggled in the back
so it's a human wave and that's not an
attack on the people coming over here
they are being rewarded by the bid
administration in exchange for breaking
our laws for mocking our constitution
they're being rewarded with public
benefits so why wouldn't they come
but the volume of this is without
precedent in american history and you
have to ask yourself what does this mean
for the country
it's obviously destabilizing but what
does it mean long term for the country
well just to give you some perspective
on the numbers here
as neil monroe at breitbart has reported
in a given year roughly three migrants
are arriving for every four americans
who were born in this country three
migrants for every four americans born
oh
remember the great replacement theory
was a conspiracy theory
it sounds more like a statistical fact
actually was there a vote on this did we
get to vote on this do people want this
democracy remember that that's where
people vote and they decide what kind of
government they get and what sort of
policies that government enacts no
no no one voted on this nobody wants
this it's happening anyway against the
will of the entire country so what did
biden say about this well here's what he
said today
on the border why is the border more
overwhelmed under your watch mr
president because there are three
countries that are never happen there
are fewer
fewer immigrants coming from central
america and from mexico
this is a totally different circumstance
what's on my watch now is venezuela
cuba and nicaragua
and the ability to send them back to
those states is not rational
you could send them back and have them
like we're working with mexico and other
countries to see if we can stop the flow
but that's the difference
well that's just completely insane of
course they're coming through mexico
and we control the mexican economy we
could turn off the mexican economy in
one minute if we wanted to of course
we're by far their biggest trading
partner and so we have an enormous
amount of leverage over the mexican
government and if we see the mexican
government not one more crosses through
your country in two hours that'd be the
end of it because no one wants to tank
with the federalists no one takes
american law enforcement seriously
because they know they're just going to
direct you to the local welfare office
nobody messes with the mexican
federalist period and everyone knows
that but we're not doing that
what biden said that is true is that as
of this fiscal year migrants and places
other than the northern triangle
countries in mexico specifically cuba
nicaragua and venezuela do make up
nearly 40 of the total apprehensions at
the border as of last month that's a 175
percent jump from last year what biden
didn't say of course is that it's all
his fault he's solely responsible for
this he stopped deporting asylum seekers
and he's allowing asylum seekers with
fraudulent claims to remain in this
country and of course the message is
going out to the world just show up and
you'll be fine
so let's say you wanted to harm the
united states what would you do well
what did fidel castro do in 1980 with
the marielle boatlift he opened his
prisons and mental hospitals and sent
him to miami thereby changing miami
forever
venezuela
is doing something very similar
venezuela's opening its prisons and
sending them here
breitbart reports tonight that dhs is
warning border officials to be on the
lookout for venezuelan convicts entering
the country dhs indicates that quote the
venezuelan government is purposely
freeing inmates including some convicted
of murder rape and extortion
it's unbelievable
again we've seen this before
and it's a catastrophe again during the
carter administration fidel castro's
government the cuban government did the
very same thing a hundred and
twenty-five thousand
people came to florida
a sun sentinel article from 1985
estimated that out of the 125 000
migrants who came at the time
16 to 20 000 were criminals the miami
district director for immigration called
it an invasion quote the boat list
should never been allowed to happen at
any other time it would have been an act
of war and bill clinton was governor of
arkansas at the time said exactly the
same thing but a lot has changed since
1995. no one in the federal government
will admit what this is which is an
invasion and of course the media are
totally for it because hey cheap
housekeepers
so
law enforcement authorities rather than
doing anything with the people invading
our country are talking about
prosecuting ron desantis
as we understand it 48 migrants were
uh lured i will use the word lord uh
under false pretenses uh on into into
staying at a hotel
for a couple of days uh they were taken
by airplane at a certain point they were
shuttled to an airplane
where they were flown to florida and
then eventually flown to martha's
vineyard again under false pretenses is
the the information that we have that
they were promised work they were
promised the solution to several of
their problems we do have the names of
some suspects involved that we believe
are persons of interest in this case at
this point but i won't be partying with
those names uh i think to be to be fair
i think everybody on this call knows who
those names are already so i won't be
naming any of them
that's appalling and shocking for any
law enforcement official a guy who
carries a gun and has a right to shoot
you
to be parroting
by demonstration political talking
points in front of a camera that man
should be ashamed
that is completely over the top that he
would say something like this this is
all crazy we're being invaded
and now they're
talking about prosecuting ron desantis
because he sent 50 people to martha's
vineyard to immediately deport so they
wouldn't get in the way of the food and
wine festival
true craziness subscribe to the fox news
youtube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from tucker
carlson tonight